Here's everything I eat in a day.
As someone that loves to cook
and is also 26 weeks pregnant,
I hate the taste of water.
So today I made a mint and lemon water
because I couldn't stomach drinking normal water.
I also have been loving apple tea in the morning,
so I've been having that.
I had these leftover croissants,
so I made a croissant bake.
I put all my sliced croissants in a loaf pan
and then made my heavy cream mixture,
top my croissants with it,
pop that in the oven.
And it was so yummy.
It was so hot.
I couldn't wait,
and I burnt all of my taste buds.
I needed a little pick me up,
as you guys know,
before lunch.
So I had a culture pop
and then got started on my fish and chips.
I wanted fish and chips,
but I wanted something a lot lighter,
so I opted to make a blanched
vegetable salad instead of the chips
and made my fish batter
and also blanched my asparagus and edamame.
Then I fried my fish,
let it rest on a wire rack while I assembled my salad,
plated that all up,
added my kimchi
dill aioli on the side,
and this was so, so good.
It was everything I wanted for dinner.
I was craving birria tacos so bad,
but I didn't wanna get take out,
so I just decided to make them myself.
I seared off my chuck roast in My pan
got it brown on all sides,
chopped up some onion,
tomato, garlic,
deseeded my chillies
and pop that in as well.
Then I blended it all up and added it back to the pot
with my chuck roast and some herbs and stock.
This was so good
that I kept stealing bites here and there
cause I just couldn't wait until dinner.
But after three to four hours
I pulled my meat out,
shredded it up
and then diced up some onion and cilantro
and then started assembling my tacos.
Dipped it in the consomme,
added all my toppings.
This was absolutely delicious.
It was better than any takeout I could get.
I've also been on a horchata kick,
so lucky got us one while I was cooking this up
and ended my night with some whipped cream and berries.